I don't think there's anything wrong
with chasing money I just think that
it's usually the quickest way not to get
it work ethic is controllable being born
with talent is not in a success world
please understand that success is
happiness not net dollars in the
motivations watch a top ten with the
lead nation grab a snack and chew on
today's lessons from a man who went from
being born in the Soviet Union operating
a lemonade stand as a kid to being a
wine critic who grew his family wine
business from three to sixty million
dollars and running vaynermedia and
Boehner X companies he's Gary Vaynerchuk
and here's my take on his top 50 rules
for success vol 3 enjoy also if you want
to know what Gary Vaynerchuk and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
like to join is in the description below
the reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one love the climb I was at the top of
the wine game and I left because I won I
didn't want to do it anymore
and went into marketing where everyone
liked the first article written about me
was like this guy huh
wine Twitter I think the article in the
big advertising magazine was Twitter
boys what they call me Twitter boy
thinks he's gonna come and win Madison
Avenue hahahahaha
they're not laughing anymore you know
and even this game now I can already
feel it I'm like oh man three four or
five years from now this thing's a rap
I'm gonna be the guy some would have to
start selling oranges or something you
know I got to figure you know I've
enough to figure something out because I
lose like I'm about to climb back to
sports I grew up with diehard Yankees
Jets Rangers Knicks fan the Yankees and
Rangers won their championships I
literally stopped watching them Knicks
and Jets are gonna take me a minute you
know but like but like I'm just about
the color I just love the climb like
even like back to sports cuz I think
it's great analogy I'll turn on a random
game I need to know who the underdog is
that's my team I'm just about to climb
you know like to me when I see a kid
wearing a Steph Curry Jersey and that
kid lives in New York I think that gets
soft
I mean it he's he's using somebody
else's success to make himself feel good
I think the biggest tell of a losing
person is wearing a jersey outside your
own City
rule number two be people centric people
ways like I can't get my cashiers to
like work because they're only 12 bucks
an hour like no it's cuz you've never
said hello to them face right so like
I'm very people centric I think there's
enormous ROI either in the short term or
the long term some of the people that
work for me
I risk me go on to win an Academy Award
as a filmmaker right like I'd much
rather have her like me than not like me
you know everybody's playing short term
I don't live as if it tomorrow I'm gonna
die and I'm stunned by how many people
do it's all short term ROI every
decision is short term ROI and I think
that's a huge decision so internally I
spend a lot of time and money my HR
department too big my time that I spend
with employees too much this is what I
hear from all my business associates who
then spend all their time asking me how
I do it your employees for me it's my
employees first then the customer then I
can even begin to think about what the
Senate for me and I've just watched 95%
of the business and I interact with
start with them then the customer then
they're in place I think that most of
the people are broken and I think if you
have if you are if you're honest
no [ __ ] right if it just went
through your mind like I am me then
customer than my employees you will lose
and I can tell you that's the majority
of businesses rule number three be
consistent I am stunned by how many
people here don't realize that the
quickest path to happiness or more
economics in business given the context
of this talk happens to be in the thing
that they love the most yet they're not
willing to eat for the next three to
five years to get there let me explain
it blows me away that I feel
ridiculously passionate
about the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
now stick with me I know this is going
weird that starting your Instagram
account your podcast and your YouTube
channel about Leonardo and Michelangelo
and putting out that content for a
three-year period in the long tail of
the Internet in the way that niche
marketing works if you focus on that
7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning around
that world that literally within three
to four years the practicality if you're
consistent to making between fifty and a
hundred thousand dollars a year in
affiliate email inks and sponsorship
around being the foremost expert of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is a very
fascinating thing how many people here
and across this country right now rushed
to buy cryptocurrency because that's
where the gold rush was I'm just
fascinated by people's passion for the
quick fix versus the marathon I'm
fascinated by people willing to put in
their body to lose 15 pounds that's some
private-label horse from China versus
eating right and exercising
let me promise you're something good and
that's how I want to say it everything
special is hard rule number four ignore
the noise I think the biggest
vulnerability you've got is you actually
value somebody's opinion more than you
value your own look the reason I've been
able to always do my thing is when I was
24 and people were like oh you work at
your dad's liquor store like I heard
that it's like a chip on my shoulder you
know I loved it I was like cool keep
sleeping on me you know like I'm glad
you're on Wall Street making a hundred
thousand buying BMWs and dumb jewelry
I'll see you in 30 years you understand
like to me the way you win is you
realize you can't hear nobody not your
parents I mean listen you got to listen
to coach and all that I get it but at
the end of the day my guy yourself you
got to get real real quiet up here I
can't hear anything
you go look at my Instagram right now my
first post I'll post something first
hundred replies in one second you're
Jesus
you walk up water you're the best you're
the all-time can't hear him the next
hundred you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
foolish you're a snake oil salesman
can't hear him I'm in my own mind doing
my own thing and that comes with
self-esteem everybody's trying to keep
up with the Joneses I'm not worried
about you being on the in the Hamptons
on a blow-up Swan
I'm not worried about you renting out
cash from the bank and putting it to
your ear I'm not worrying you jumped a
fence and took a photo in front of a
private plane what do you think these
people are doing they're posing patients
long game you know what's amazing about
being an entrepreneur we get to play
forever I'm gonna be working when I'm 96
trying to find my next hustle rule
number five sync differently first thing
that you need to think about is you need
to thinking about yourself as ESPN and
HBO and CNBC and the New York Times the
quicker all of you think of yourself as
that everything changes I literally
think that I garyvee don't compete with
Richard Branson or with you know Mark
Cuban I think that Gary Vee competes
with Business Insider
and Forbes and and you know the Wall
Street Journal and complex magazine like
I I don't think about competing with
humans
I spend zero time even debating that and
so I think of myself Carlos is a media
company and so it's the difference
between you know what I think a lot of
people do in our world they turn into
infomercials versus 20/20 if you make
content on Facebook and LinkedIn and
your email and everything you do if you
think of yourself as ABC News if you
think about yourself as fox or CNN
instead of an infomercial changes
everybody's thinking like an advertiser
not as a media company and I think for a
lot of me it seems like you know I'm
watching your kind of behavior that's
why I feel a little bit different
I'm not putting out content like an
advertiser with a short-term goal I'm
putting out content like a media company
with a long-term goal which creates
short-term opportunity it's a very very
subtle but disproportionate reason and
and the luckier you are if you're this
legendary as people are whispering to me
well then that means you're sitting with
something which means you should be
recording all of it
all of it achieve that's right and the
way to think about it is some of you
don't have the dollars to hire somebody
yet and neither did I for the first
eight years the whole d-roc thing and
all this doesn't you know I love what
never was like easy for you Gary
you have d-roc now in it I'm like pick I
didn't have anybody for eight years and
I build up to it and then I had somebody
so like if you got to do it in selfie
form good and if like for me I can't
write I've ghostwriter for my books I've
a ghostwriter for my LinkedIn a medium
right now I can't write it's not how I
communicate but I can do video some of
you are scared of video and get awkward
you're more introverted so then right
use the medium that helps you best
communicate and then build around it
rule number six stop complaining nobody
is gonna cry for you they have their own
tears one thing one thing I'm positive
about is how are Y negative complaining
is and how much I'm trying to suffocate
the practice of it I really have been
fascinated by people that have changed
their mindset into understanding that
everything that is not going well right
now is their fault it has been
remarkably important to me in
understanding that everything that I'm
not happy about has on me it's it's a
remarkably interesting brain twist the
amount of energy spent on things that
you can't control versus being
accountable to what you can control has
been a huge separator for me in the last
four or five years as I've dug deep no
question the quickest way to happiness
is accountability when people start
looking for somebody else to be at fault
whether it's the government or their
aunt or some or their boss they always
lose rule number seven find your why
everybody's putting out the best photo
from their vacation ever
everybody's putting out the most
exciting night of their lives people are
actually now doing things in real life
just for the photo to put on Instagram
and this is very important to understand
because we as humans are wired often to
envy and be jealous and curious and
dwell on not being on that boat and what
that leads to is short-term behavior
everybody's looking to make a quick
dollar so that they can go on that yacht
or go to Ibiza or buy that car or that
bag or that sneaker and this is 100% the
poison that is in the system and so for
me I want to know why why do you want to
be successful for me I didn't even
really necessarily want to be successful
I just couldn't breathe if I wasn't
selling something or building a business
it's all I knew there was nothing else
it was why I was such a bad student
I couldn't even appease the hour I
needed to be a decent student a day
because I needed every minute selling
baseball cards or wine or whatever I was
up to at that point in my life there was
no choice and so that's what I wish on
everybody else I wish that you wake up
every morning and have no choice that
what you do is how you breathe rule
number eight get attention let's say you
opened a bar a barber shop you want to
sell t-shirts like the one big advantage
you guys have look I have a huge company
my company's gonna do 200 million
dollars in revenue I just flew from
Kraft we have Budweiser we have the
biggest brands in the world chase they
still don't get it I'm sitting the
meetings every day and they're not
pouring enough money into social media
that's your advantage they're still
pouring it into commercials and print
and things of that nature
so you know where the attention is and
so social matters but humans and
relationships are just honestly my man I
said it like I can't explain to you
enough how much I want you to meet every
person look some of you are introverts
if you're an extrovert and you're social
you need to go all-in on the fact that
you got blessed with that DNA that you
love people and you love saying hello
and you've got the leverage of doing
what you're doing now some of you are
introverts right and that's hard but
like
I'm gonna keep pushing - because the
lever just absurd rule number nine be
self-aware most people here will be
successful if they could be more patient
for longer yet most people will fail in
here if they're delusional and keep
doing the same thing for a long time
waiting for the thing to happen it's one
in the same the most difficult question
for me to answer is when should you stop
doing what you're doing
because I actually have to spend time
with you and really look under the hood
to know are you completely in outer
space and have a terrible idea and you
stink and of course we should change it
or the other thing that so many people
struggle with you're so impatient and
you're so caught up in short-term
metrics like how many followers you have
or how many sales you made or how many
leads did you generate that you quit too
soon because nothing happens overnight
it's one in the same rule number ten
make an impact dudes that were trying to
kill it didn't use words like empathy
and gratitude seven years ago like Felix
leaped up like rad dudes roll up to me
like you know kindness dawg honestly I
genuinely believe my great legacy
potentially may be that I made
emotionally intelligent soft-skills
alpha you know you'll never believe this
is a super interesting to me
the fact that pink was a boys color and
blue was a girl's color back in the day
is kind of how I think about gratitude
empathy kindness I'm like I'm gonna
trick these young dogs into like
thinking this is cool and then one day
in 50 years people gonna be like the
alpha male traits are like gratitude and
kindness and if I could pull that off
then it's like remember 11 loves the
game
I don't think there's anything wrong
with chasing money I just think that
it's usually the quickest way not to get
it
I really believe that I really do I
think when I watch people that are
driven by money I see a lot of
unhappiness and failure
it's very common if we did the happy
meter here it's the people that are I
promise you it's the people that are
doing what they want to be doing like to
me I couldn't explain to you enough and
I have the most empathy for the cynicism
around this statement it's unbelievable
how much I don't like money I like the
game I love my game I love the game of
building I wake up at six o'clock in the
morning go garage saling because there's
nothing like pulling up literally to
this day I can't replicate the high of
going to a garage sale walking into a
yard of junk and finding something for a
dollar that I know I can sell on eBay
for 17 bucks is a bigger happiness high
than closing a six million dollar
account for Vayner
and it's not even close that's what I
want for everybody because that's how
they get the twenty rule number 12
be prepared opportunity meets
preparation that's something a lot of
people talk about I'll tell you what I
believe in I believe that there's so
much opportunity at all times that it's
actually preparation everybody prepared
finds their opportunity yeah so so sure
I believe in it but here's what I
actually believe in opportunity is
abundant mm-hmm we live in a world that
has unlimited opportunity especially if
you're willing to look for it hmm
looking for it is predicated on the fact
that you put in the work you put in the
work because you knew that you were
gonna go look for it so I believe in
preparation preparation preparation
because I just believe that opportunity
is almost like oxygen
it's everywhere always and some
opportunities are bigger than others but
preparation man people don't do people
convince themselves before they start
that the world is unjust or they can't
there's things are up they complain they
dwell they say no before they say yes
and of course look if you say no it's
already over like a litter if you wake
up and say it's not gonna happen for me
it's already over you you might as well
not try real numbers
Dean understand time my friends this is
a remarkably special time and I'm
completely commenced the far majority
and I mean 99% of this room is going to
regret it I'm completely convinced about
it it's not fun for me to say that but
it's very obvious to me that humans take
for granted and are really bad at
perspective and timing the reason i
pushed patients how many people here are
under 30 raise your hands
stand up if you're under 30 don't be a
dick stand up let's first of all clap it
up for all the youngsters in the room
keep standing
you're young you're not tired yet if
you're standing right now you really
have like let's get into perspectives
and actual understanding if you're
standing right now with the way that
modern medicine is actually evolving
there's a very high percentage that
you're gonna live three more lives that
you've already lived if not five like do
you understand why I struggle when
people give up on a year or two in or
upset that they haven't gotten there yet
three years in when you phases are about
to live four more lives I'm being
serious
like you're literally gonna live four
more lives five more like from the day
you were born that you cannot remember -
right this second you're about to do
that three to four more times
you can sit literally literally your
biggest advantage is timing for all the
great things that I have in my life I
would literally give it up all of it all
of it just to be 25 I would give up for
17 years I'd give up everything I have
because that's how valuable time is and
the far majority of this room has time
time as their asset and every day the
number one asset they have time they
give away by being impatient mainly on
the back of listening to society or
their parents that they have to have
their figured out at this age the fact
that people
actually think at 1822 or 30 you have to
have your figured out is ridiculous let
me promise you all those parents and
uncles and grandparents that push down
your throat that you have to figure it
out by now they still haven't figured at
the town I mean it
so this nonsense this nonsense that you
have to have it figured out at eighteen
twenty to thirty you know many people
freak the [ __ ] out at thirty how many
feeler thirty right now that was crazy
right
like people lose their at thirty like
meanwhile their kid and so I'm
unbelievably aware lately that one of
the you know people are just like why do
you when I talk about my parents and not
coming from anything but the more that I
live on like no reason I really win is
cuz I understand time and listen I know
I can get hit by a bus or get terminally
ill I get it here's the problem that's
far more unlikely for the majority of us
the math works in your favor and we are
stunningly not patient patience has been
the foundation of my sick patients
adversity these are the foundations of
my success
rule number fourteen work harder the
reason I love hard work is it's
controllable it's hard for me be like be
more talented
you know that seems like like when
people like you push hard thinking a lot
of politically correct you know over
extreme European points of you get mad
at me for Gary you're it's unhealthy
you can't garyvee you can't go to the
grave with all your money I'm like Tina
I'm not talking about money and I don't
feel like it's work when I love it
like maybe you don't like your job as
much rule number 15 do the 1% things
you're asking for a 1% of 1% life so far
I've heard I didn't want to eat and put
out stuff and deal with no feedback for
a year or two I don't want to spend the
three or four hours to like learn it cuz
it seems like there's so much you have
to realize when you're asking to do to
live a 1% life that you need to do 1%
things dude I've worked in a liquor
store for 15 hours a day 7 days a week
for years and somehow people put that as
like part of my narrative but don't give
it the respect rule number 16 focus on
the context the word that drives my life
is actually context not content I talked
so much about content the reason I am
successful at what I do and my companies
are successful and the companies I
advise are successful and the people
that follow are successful is because
they're great at context not just
content clearly if you don't have
context on the other person if you're
not deploying empathy for the other
person if you're not worried about them
then you have no shot it's really no
different than giving a speech the
reason I'm a dominant public speaker and
one of the best at what I do is because
I'm far more worried in the next 32
minutes plus about delivering you value
and giving stuff for you not what I can
get out of it for me you know some
speakers get confused and they want your
money I don't want your money I want you
to win and then send me an email that
you've won remember 17 don't worry about
losses the other thing I'm a very big
believer in is getting people to not
feel like it's a scarlet letter if they
lose something nobody talks about at all
is your scenario you jump it fails you
reset and go back and get a job in the
craft that you had because of your
resume and you restart in four years
from now we have we so America is pretty
good at looking at losses in a positive
way compared to other parts of the world
where it's like a true Scarlet Letter
death forever but still even here you
know people don't know when to go back
from their jump because they don't want
the loss on the resume they made the big
to-do that they're gonna you're gonna do
it now it doesn't work and what they do
is they triple down into debt
to look good in front of people oh
you're preaching that I want you've
already done that I'm actually talking
about the next part which is having the
options to know that the game is super
long and that if the Bisby okay when you
go through ice cold when you go from
never having a business to having a
business that's like literally asking me
I'm asking you to right now qualify for
Wimbledon and tennis it's a lot harder
than people think you're grown you too
are grown I'm not trying to suppress by
the way I'm talking about the
practicality of like options I love that
we live in a world I'm trying to get
people to like really understand how to
win this so much of my success is
completely predicated on not worrying
about all my losses which means at times
of you know my great losses or the
things I passed on maybe I should have
done Shark Tank
maybe maybe maybe not I don't think I
should have done it not this late in I
think I'll do my own thing like you know
like but I could but I mean there's a
lot of time you know I didn't invest in
uber
when I thought I made $400 I mean that's
a loss rule number 18 stop listening to
others tip of the day stop listening to
anybody but yourself outside noises so
many of them
imagine athletes stopping every time
they heard people booing then we're
talking while they were on the court
that's how I think about being an
entrepreneur like of course or just
living life but just imagine that like
you're in a free throw line on somebody
not you just they cry or they don't take
the shot remember 19 be realistic I do
think people are capable of dramatically
more than they expect but you know
there's you know listen I could be a
dramatically bet bigger and better
singer than I am right now which isn't
zero but there's also a very fine line
of extending yourself and then bleeding
into delusion there there is no scenario
where I'm gonna be Frank Sinatra or
Beyonce yeah
and so I think one of the things that I
worry about especially in my field of
entrepreneurship do I think that most
people can replicate their salary at a
job that they hate by starting an online
business and over a seven-year period
make the same amount of money talking
about or producing content or selling
things around skiing or Jam making or
shoes than they did as being a miserable
clerk at a retail store yes I do do I
think most people are capable of making
a million dollars a year running a
business no I do not and I think that's
in a very it's a where I think these
debates become too black and white and
some people like oh it's just about
mindset and positivity and you can do it
and everybody's a hater and a troll or
the reverse where people like all these
people are foolish they're selling them
[ __ ] and snake oil the reason that
is and the reason I wrote crush it if
you have a really really read it
I believe in passion and optimism and
pushing yourself but I
disproportionately believe in
practicality patience and hard work to
rule number 20 communicate with the
world the number one thing practical
that you could get out of this talk go
home and start doing is realize that if
you're not communicating to the world
then you're in trouble because attention
is the asset and whether you're
producing content or you're running
advertising if you're not doing one of
those two things you're actually really
vulnerable my biggest concern is there's
a lot of people here who are actually
having a good year how many people here
are having their best year in their
business raise your hands
that's phenomenal excites the enemy it
also scares me to no end because if
you're winning without the stuff that I
believe in it means that you're
vulnerable the reason you're seeing
videos of me pop up talking about Toys R
Us or Sears or other thing in trouble
and now it makes me look really smart is
because seven or eight years ago they
weren't doing the things that I knew
they had to do to be successful today
that became their vulnerability if
you're selling a ton of homes or you're
getting more clients than ever or your
whatever it is whatever success you're
having if you're doing that without
producing a high volume of content every
day on Facebook Twitter Linkedin
Instagram you know YouTube or a podcast
you're immediately right this second
vulnerable because somebody else is
going to and over time they will take
your audience they will and so I highly
recommend that the tangible thing that
you do from this talk is that you
realize that you have to go home and
figure out how you're gonna communicate
to the world
rule number 21 chase happiness happiness
is so important I'm so obsessed with it
right now and I hate that success and
entrepreneurship and all this stuff have
been put on a pedestal
do you understand that most people think
they need to make a million dollars a
year to be like winning meanwhile in
America one of the richest countries in
the world four hundred forty thousand
dollars is the entry into the 1% we we
have success completely come
pletely misunderstood we have success
completely misunderstood let me tell you
what success looks like when you wake up
in the morning and you're happy
rule number 22 hustle I talk about
hustle here's why if I looked at all of
us right now and everybody behind these
cameras or reading this article and said
get smarter more talented I want you to
get more talented that's very tricky
that's unbelievably ideological advice
if I said look two extra hours of work
actually has an impact on your success
if that's what you're trying to achieve
that's practical yeah you don't have to
but it's controllable work ethic is
controllable being born with talent is
not rule number 23 love the dark clouds
everybody wanted to be an astronaut one
day like it every kid that been looking
at these good-looking kids they all
wanted to be astronauts and pilots in
1957 what do they want to be now
entrepreneurs I mean this is my moment
and by the way it'll be fun and in nine
years the world will melt
everybody will not be an entrepreneur
anymore it won't be cool they'll blame
entrepreneurship for the melt and I'll
still be an entrepreneur cuz that's what
I've always been that's what I am now
and that's what I'll be to the last
breath if you're a purebred entrepreneur
you love the dark clouds you understand
that the fake entrepreneurship hero we
live through loves the sunshine when
it's good
happy and easy but if it's in your DNA
if you actually are not executed you
know exactly why the upcoming year of
dark clouds is going to be very
important because at the end of the day
this is a game based on merit and if you
don't know how to navigate those storms
you can't be in all time on to the world
I love the dark clouds because they're
part of the problem dream number 24
change your mindset how many hands work
somewhere but want to do their own thing
raise your hands
more than half this audience meanwhile
let me tell you why most of the hands
that just went up will never get there
they by dumb do you know how many people
here literally drive cars to impress
people that they hate people literally
going in debt or getting further from
leaving the job they don't like to do
something they'll make them happy
because they have to buy a certain car
that has a logo that impresses people
that they despise do you understand up
up that is do you know many people here
live in homes where they don't use more
than half the rooms in the house like we
are so fundamentally in a vortex that
makes no sense that I am unbelievably
passionate understanding how much money
you make and what you can do to get off
of it but the problem is again people
are doing so many things to keep up with
the Joneses to make it look like they're
successful to appease their parents and
a million other things that have nothing
to do with themselves and we need to
change that game rule number 25
advertised properly in 1996 my dad had a
liquor store in New Jersey
that's as traditional as you get yeah
that was 22 years ago and and I put my
dad's store on online and I did email
marketing and I did Google and I did
content and in a couple months after
YouTube came out I started YouTube show
in 2006 which is now 12 years ago I I I
have no respect
or and normally I deploy a lot of
empathy I struggled deploying empathy I
struggled deploying compassion if you
were a business operator in 2018 had a
koe about I'm recording this in October
2019 which is a majority people gonna
listen this and you and your excuses
well I'm a pub or I make tomato juice or
I have three restaurants like a digital
is oxygen it's it's it's the real world
feels secondary like to not be a
communicator content producer part of
the conversation it's it's now it's gone
from cute and naive to grossly negligent
you know and I just think it's
unacceptable to be a business in 2019 in
the same way that it would be to pay
people not minimum wage like I literally
believe it's grossly unacceptable like
to me it's like it's like to quantify
digital versus traditional just
marketing like really you think sending
direct mail print is a better thing to
do than advertising on Instagram as a
restaurant like like really like really
sit down with me you're telling me right
now that it's a better deal to spend all
that money making a flier and sending it
the rekt mail or running a radio ad or
buying a small little ad in a newspaper
like this is what you're telling me
it is 2019 I felt bad in 2002 it was
really the internet was new I had
compassion it was cute
in 2007 it was like hmm it was kind of
like uh not like hey annoying kind of
like hmm but still kind of in 2012 is
like you're not smart in 2019 like you
deserve to die
remember 26 make sacrifices everybody
thinks I'm so lucky and I'm like you're
lucky you went to high school parties I
worked I went home 75% of my weekends
during my college career taking Amtrak
not even an Axela no first-class Amtrak
sending a [ __ ] sandwich which I kind
of loved and I missed that sandwich get
get into New York not New York not even
New York which would be fun Woodbridge
New Jersey train station at like eight
o'clock my dad would pick me up we drive
home and then I would wake up at 6:30 in
the morning and work in the liquor store
on Saturday and then leave back to
Boston on Sunday and now I'm lucky it's
hard to it's hard to think you're lucky
when you when nobody else is reading
rule number 27
keep things in perspective we put out a
shoe with k-swiss that was our third one
with them called clouds and dirt which
is basically my thesis in life which is
macro micro the have ambitions but you
have to you have to put in work to do
that right like you know everything
matters nothing matters just I'm a very
I'm a contradiction and within that
contradiction and a lot of people hit me
up they're like you're a stoic I'm like
what is that I google them like oh maybe
maybe I am like I was like what what I
know I am is happy and I'm happy because
I keep things in perspective and keeping
things in perspective I just tweeted
something that said there's a very fine
line between perseverance and delusion
and it's this question of people always
ask me like when should I give up Gary
I've been doing this you know rapping
thing I've been doing this vlog doing
this restaurant it's not going well two
and a half years in and I can never
answer it
because you need to know the nuances and
the details sure but there is an
incredible inflection point in
everybody's life speaking about your
early childhood like acting the amount
of people that literally were like one
more audition this isn't working for me
one more audition and that's the one
right or one more song one more album
one more startup one more day at their
job there's a one more try to ask this
boy out there's all these things of like
when is it too much and you just waste
your life and you go into depression or
when was it perfect contradictions I'm
fascinated by them but I'm always on the
optimistic side of them mainly because
when it doesn't work out
my big thing is well you now know what
doesn't work you now know you aren't a
rapper and good news you're 31 just your
whole life is energy
we're number 28 be practical do you
understand how crazy it is that if you
went to the clearance aisles of your
five biggest retailers in Australia
bought things on clearance when home
relisted it and post it on ebay that the
far majority of this audience could make
between fifty to a hundred thousand
dollars a year just on doing that for
nine to ten hours a day meanwhile
everybody's sitting here with the next
big app that's gonna be the next Boober
for lawnmowers the thing that has made
me successful far more than my passion
or my energy is my disproportion of
practicality most people want to look
the part of an entrepreneur that came up
with the next supreme or adidas brand or
the next uber or face book yet our
$40,000 in debt work in a job that they
hate and literally if they went to the
five discount stores that dominate this
market buy things on clearance go home
take a picture with their phone and
upload to ebay and then when people buy
it go to the post office and ship it
they would be able to get out of debt
and get into a financial place but
people don't want to do that because
they don't want to be judged for that
being there hustle most people in this
room and this world would rather lose
looking like they're doing something
successful than win and be judged for
doing something that seems dorky rule
number 29 love what you do I think that
there's a deep inherent understanding in
my in my mind that there's only one at
that
and I don't want to leave anything on
the table most people don't want to work
most people didn't find what they love
most people don't have enormous ambition
and most people prefer to you to stop
because it makes them insecure while you
keep winning there's no greater gift in
life than to have the people you love be
happy and healthy the second biggest
gift in life is to love what you do so
much that you only want to work remember
30 be authentic what's your question the
life I like for me yeah cuz it's my
natural state cuz I'm optimistic and
positive I love to compliment people if
it's off that dick it's like if I can
you think you're purple here is rad then
I'll be like your hair is amazing I
would never do it if I knew who you were
and I wanted to get to be your friend
I wouldn't say it I genuinely believe
that intent rules the world that if
you're doing it for the right reason you
win I'd rather say something about your
jacket or your sneakers or or just say
hello but what my favorite thing is is
if there's something that I want to
compliment something on because it just
starts the vibes so nice rule number 31
have self-awareness the number one thing
you need to do is deploy self-awareness
about yourself and how you want to
communicate and what you want to
communicate the reality of trying to be
successful is super fascinating
everybody has the ambition or thought
process of living a 1% life but the far
majority have no interest in putting in
the work ethic of the 1% that is
required for that life and that's fine
you know another thing that's a complete
contradiction is how many people I know
that are far happier when their business
the amount of people I've really looked
at a lot of businesses at this point you
know hundreds of thousands probably over
the last 20 years because of my
investing career there are so many
people that have a business that makes
them two hundred thousand a year they
want to grow and then when it goes to
280,000 they went from extremely happy
to miserable on that small of a Delta
you know please please in a sex
world please understand that success is
happiness not net dollars in I literally
replied to I have a ridiculously funny
post on Instagram right now right let my
last post about me garage saleing and a
lot of the comments were like literally
things like I don't get it why is
somebody who's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars going out there and
buying things for a dollar and selling
it for fifteen bucks and I literally am
in there like on the road here like
we're plying to some of you when I'm
gonna be on stage and replying an
Instagram to kids that are asking me
that I'm replying happiness I Gary as a
human get dramatically happier when I go
to a garage sale and buy something worth
twenty bucks for a dollar and get the
high of discovering it and knowing that
I'm gonna pay a dollar and sell it for
twenty then I do when I land a seven
million dollar deal for vaynermedia and
by the way there's no comparison that's
just who I am
rule number thirty-two play outside the
rules you know I hate things like nice
guys finish last where it's just not
true
nice guys might be losing at halftime
but they win the game nice guys always
win it's just so crazy
all this fodder in the system that isn't
true all the faking it to you make it as
a fashion brand that's a great or at
what every single twenty three-year-old
male in the world is doing which is
fronting on Instagram because boys want
girls you know and so like I'm just
unbelievably passionate in trying to
what I realized about myself was oh the
reason I won and I'm good is I've never
played in the vortex I've never played
in the actual rules of life I was an F
student when every immigrant was
supposed to be an A student because
education was the way out I launched an
e-commerce wine business in 1996 right
like that wasn't I have a sneaker thanks
for wearing them
like I've always done things that don't
make sense
I play outside of the actual game and
that has been where all my happiness has
come from and so many things have become
obvious to me by playing outside of the
rules playing outside of the rules is
the best and that's where I want people
to understand we are pandering to so
many things that just aren't true
rule number 33 loves the hustle this is
real quick cuz there's a lot of bubbling
up of like Gary you're pushing people to
work too hard and all this stuff and I'm
watching it I'm like I love one elitists
who work their faces off to make a bunch
of money then tell everybody else
nothing worked hard so so so to me if
you love what you're doing and you're
happy and you're mentally and physically
healthy do you I'm not judging anybody
about doing anything but it's all about
self-awareness and could and putting a
framework around where you don't keep up
with the Joneses I don't want to go
skiing face it I do not want to go
seeing I do not want to go to a beer
garden it is not fun for me to go look
at a museum I am NOT interested in
watching Netflix I am NOT interested
that doesn't mean that I think everybody
else should do that I think and I've
said consistently self-awareness
happiness I've said it a million times
do I believe in hustle yes I do I like
work ethic it's controllable do I want
that to put you into depression or
health scares ya of course not
face but don't sit on a pedestal after
you've worked hard for 15 years and then
tell all these kids that they should
have work-life balance
yes rule number 34 change your
perspectives I love when people like
Gary's eat like the comments are just so
fun Gary Vee like you suck bro you
repeat the same I'm like cuz it's right
face the reason I keep repeating it the
reason I believe in it is because I know
for so many of you even though you've
seen it eighty seven times this moment
in real life but this time might be the
time it happens that's how it actually
works this is a game of perspective
either you understand what's happening
or not do you know many people have
defaulted into thinking this is a
terrible time my friends this is the
greatest time to be a human being in the
history of Earth I mean I don't know
what else to tell you this is like math
this is not my opinion this is what's
going on with genocide and health life
expense it like this is the best like
for all the we have with racism and
sexism and a lot of tarrant we've got
plenty of meanwhile they had the Black
Plague meanwhile they had World War two
meanwhile they had real and we sit
around and complain about the dumbest in
the world people complain about like
getting the wrong milk in their coffee
from a barista or that you're what this
is my your Wi-Fi is a little slower than
normal [ __ ] like you're upset you can
feel the speed is a little lower or for
my or you got a few less likes then
you're usually getting on a putt like
the stuff that we actually spend time on
is fascinating to me it is a complete
and utter lack of perspective rule
number 35 have the good intent I know
what how easy it is when your intent is
good do you know how do you know why I
film everything I'm not scared of
anything I have good intent you know why
I don't sell products or things that
make sure it's because I don't need to I
make my money in different businesses
not that it has anything wrong with that
everybody can do whatever they want if
you know that your intent is good it's
easy even I think about weird guys I
think about like what if I hit somebody
when I was driving what about
killed somebody this is that goes from
my head what if I'm driving and I kill
somebody because they jumped out wasn't
painted or worst you know this is what I
read why I really stopped texting and
driving even a little bit like what if
that happened and it's crazy the way I
play chess in my head it would obviously
change the course of my life and
devastate me but it's incredible why
there's still this little voice in my
head that still makes it not okay oh boy
do I give a [ __ ] about intent it's
incredible how much I navigate
everything based on intent I will let
everything right dear Rach we talked
about the other day about like how I
manage I I don't get down on anybody
I don't scream it and if your intent is
good it's all okay if I don't think
you're capable I'll fire you and try to
help you get another job and I'm being
dead serious I do it all the time
there's nothing wrong with that but I'm
unbelievably always so passionate about
intent if your intent is good you're
good with me forever
period rule number 36 don't try to
impress others most people spend money
on dumb things which then forces them to
do things they don't want so step number
one for most people in here they should
sell their home take the money and go
read they should return their BMW and
get a Toyota
[Music]
and that's Hawaii and honestly that
becomes the vulnerability why do you
want to BMW so to me that's where it
gets interesting right do you or do you
like what the brand does to make you
look to other people I don't know I'm
not assuming I don't know
I don't know you but I know in the macro
that 90% of people that buy a Mercedes
or BMW lights when it makes other people
think
not that they like it and that 487
dollars a month versus what they really
need which is $100 a month is why do
they have a job they hate because
they're paying for a life that means
nothing
and they buy things they don't care
about to impress people they rule number
37 be optimistic debated full of
optimism do you have down days everybody
has down days and I'm so scared to
answer truthfully which is what I always
do it's surprising how not really I
basically feel that down days are saved
for the death of people you love I
genuinely believe everything else is
that sudden level controllable if I was
to lose money if a bad deal happened if
a lot of people you know turned on me or
made fun of me for some reason those
things don't bother me as much the the
death or terminal illness of 20 or 30
people that matter to me the most that
scares me
that's when I'll have a down day if you
come back here and we're hanging out in
six years I would say yes today
knock on wood somebody died right yeah
not getting the deal that I wanted I'm
I'm always optimistic and positive about
me I don't judge myself the way I think
most people do I don't beat myself up
when I have a bad hour day week or month
and that's what I think most people do
rule number 38 don't create friction for
your audience the number one thing you
should never do is create friction for
your audience do you know how many of
you are miss playing it because you've
stopped posting anywhere but Instagram
because that's where your biggest
audience is you become fundamentally 100
percent vulnerable to a platform go
speak to all the people that blew up on
MySpace how that works out rule number
39 prioritize when you're working with
family
how do you balance the love that you
guys have for each other with you know
getting tough feedback all the time
comes
yeah I'm believe it's the most typical
thing you know business is business and
Families family and those are two you
know blood is thicker than water you
know you know these are unbelievably
difficult things to me it's like a 50.0
50.1 it's not even 5149 that i like to
throw around family businesses are more
50.1 to 49.9 than where you have to be
all about the family as you can imagine
if you actually understand what I just
said it leads to a lot of tough tough
conversations and a lot of conflicts and
a lot of being very careful and
threading the needle very carefully at
the end of the day for me personally I
was always in a position in the family
business where I was making the core
operational decisions so I had to put
the logo ahead of anything else in the
Mike Rowe I was willing to shut down the
business if I thought it was gonna
undermine my family relationship of my
brother and my dad but on a day-to-day
basis in the micro I always pushed for
the thing that I thought was best for
the business
got it rule number 40 finds your past I
don't like losing
I like going through the process of
trying to win like a bit of pain I do I
do struggle because because I think it's
appropriate for my ambition
like I think that there should be pain
because my ambition is so great of
course I should have a lot of micro
losses champions lose rounds they
sometimes even lose fights
Muhammad Ali lost five times but he's an
all-time legend or sexually you know
yeah what was great for me was because I
was an entrepreneur I tested it from the
beginning I was I was learning at five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen time I was 22 I was a veteran
in my craft I wasn't just starting most
people are in school and just started 22
I was an old player in my game at 22 I'd
been selling and building businesses my
whole life for real like I know people
know my narratives at least the ones
that are watching them know I don't
think I actually really know like I
really did business every minute always
my whole life it's what I'm passion
about it's what I loved in the summer I
chose to wash people's carves for money
I chose rule number 41 grind if you've
got debt or have to put a roof over your
head or somebody else then you work
whatever job is paying that but I'm
asking you what are you doing from 6:00
p.m. to midnight and if you have to go
build slowly your portfolio your Shopify
store your Instagram account your
YouTube channel your content like like
wouldn't you be pumped if I told you for
the next four years it's tough and you
don't watch as much Netflix and Sports
and hanging out but then you get to live
happy for the rest of your life
everybody in theory would sign up for
that the reality is a lot of people
don't want to grind for four years like
people don't like pain it's why most
people don't have six-packs
I mean that I mean that there's a lot of
people here who want to be a better
shape you just don't want to workout you
just don't want to eat well it
rule number 42 love yourself I love
being self-aware
I suck at a lot of things I just don't
think about them like I can't read for
sure I interrupt people when I interview
them 24/7 everyone a super pissed on the
internet about that not good cuz I
already know what the person saying I
can't help but I'm sorry there's plenty
of things that I'm not good at I love
self-awareness I like it's kept me so
happy
like you know I'm not upset at myself
that I'm selfish in certain areas that's
human I think that we just don't love
each other ourselves enough I I think we
I don't know who's perfection I'm trying
to live up to like if I like silly
things like people get on me for biting
my nails Jusuf like people are just
creating themselves all day long rule
number 43 stop looking for shortcuts for
so many people that are complaining that
they don't have a big enough audience
how do you have the audacity to wish for
more fans when you don't go into your
own comments when you only get 17 of
them and reply to the people that are
already part of your community from 2007
to 2011 when nobody knew who the guy was
and Twitter was the platform of the day
I spent every day replying to every
single tweet that made a mention of me
and used to go to sleep at 3 and 4
o'clock in the morning until I
completely got to everybody and that's
how I built my foundation people want
the glitz and the glamour and the caviar
but they're not willing to eat this
period if I mean if you don't understand
how this actually plays out there is no
shortcut
there's no hack there's no tip there's
just the work rule number 44 ignore the
opinions of others every single thing
I've ever done in my life people thought
was stupid until they did it well
because when you do something early or
that isn't mainstream yet it's always
gonna be met with cynicism
[Music]
the internet was a fad when I started
the whole thing the whole internet not
flipping not Instagram no whole
framework was gonna be gone by the year
2000 all these people told me y2k is
gonna kill the Internet this is some of
the [ __ ] that I heard from like people
that didn't know dream number 45 be an
entrepreneur first I was a super
entrepreneurial kid you know it's very
rare for somebody growing up in the 80s
who's an immigrant to not be blindly
bought into education as the way out
miraculously I have such a great mother
who saw a four five set I mean young
five six seven eight year old kid
basically spend all his time on business
lemonade you know I was a four season
executive you know in the fall I'm
raking leaves in the winter I'm
shoveling snow and singing Christmas
carols at your door I mean I literally I
don't talk about that a lot I literally
rang people's doors I'd be like do you
wanna will you pay us a dollar to sing
jingle bells via my crew I mean it was a
little crazy or Jewish or and I'm Jewish
I mean talk about I'm entrepreneur first
you know in the spring it was like we
did a I remember we did a miniature golf
course
we did flea Mar mini flea markets it was
a garage sale in the summer it was
hardcore washing cars of lemonade I was
so passionate and then very quickly for
a lot of people watching they'll
probably remember this in the late 80s
early 90s the baseball card phenomenon
in America happened and I was at the
forefront not only was I collecting but
as a 12 year old I'm in in hotels in
malls in convention centers set up as a
dealer with other 30 40 50 year old men
and really cut my teeth there and then
my 14th birthday came and I first
whatever reason I guess that's grown up
in Russia land my dad at this point in
parallel was also an entrepreneur more a
more significant one saved up all his
money as a stock boy and then manager of
a liquor store which is the job he got
in America and bought
a liquor store and dragged me into that
liquor store in Springfield New Jersey
when I was 14 and so from eighth grade
on I worked
rule number 46 flipped us one of the
things I saw a lot in my comments cuz I
read them all was well I have no money
I'm like I lived my whole life with no
money but I figured it out I would just
buy I would buy garage sales and it just
got me going going I love it it's like a
hobby of mine to go garage so doing that
was close I did I used to do a close
dude the amount goes especially like a
stylish kid like you like if you have
flavor if you're listening right now and
you don't have money but you're cool or
you got flavor you got swag you got
style if you just spend your life in
goodwill and in thrift stores yeah and
by that you think is fresh and then wear
it and take a selfie and put it on eBay
for three times the price or like I see
every day the amount of people that buy
three dollar t-shirts and sell them for
35 bucks on eBay and Etsy and Facebook
marketplace is enormous
there's no excuse in America to say you
have no money even if you're in the
deepest poorest places because if you
can literally get a dollar you can buy
your first t-shirt at Goodwill and get
it up for 15 bucks on Facebook because
you know what's funny what's funny
everybody's got a smartphone like you go
into the poorest places in America and
everybody's got a smartphone which means
you have the Internet I mean listen the
homeless
you've got people all over on home
homeless smart phones I get emails every
day I'm homeless I watch you on YouTube
rule number 47 love the process I've
never done anything financial a lot of
good things have happened to me that has
remotely hit my radar more than the year
I made a hundred thousand a year I would
argue that if you really knew everything
about me and you read it all every
action I ever did you would look me in
the face and ask me why do you sabotage
yourself in business and financials
environments and I would tell you that
deep down subconsciously I love it so
much that I just want it to happen
forever and so for me making it
is is a for you no it's just there is
that's what that's what blows me away
about somebody who's like I just need to
make a million bucks and I'm gonna go to
Jamaica right or or like I I don't have
that I don't have that in my head I just
want to play forever and that's why I'm
trying to get people to understand the
process because I it is very clear to me
that people that are in love with their
craft and process can win and that's why
I'm trying to change the conversation
around how much money you need to be
happy because it doesn't work like I
just know unbelievable amounts of data
of how many people have lots of money
how many people don't have lots of money
by our standards and how happy they are
and it doesn't take a lot of money to be
you know to be alive in society it's
about what you spend it money on rule
number 48 have empathy you like reading
the comments love you do own every video
every post all day how do you how do you
deal with the negativity someone's
talking about biting your nails
empathetic mmm empathy somebody just
watched 49 seconds of me spitting some
pontification on Instagram and they've
decided to make a judgment on me and I
respect that I put myself out there they
don't know everything about me so when
they dragged me down be like this guys
have made it here's foolish or what the
[ __ ] I'm like that make sense they saw
me in the Explorer feature they're like
who's this face they watch it they don't
like it and these items and they're not
in a good place so they have to drag
down I deploy them but the first sucks
to be I would never do that as a happy
person to anybody else so hey I'm
already feel bad yeah and be who the
[ __ ] am i they only got 49 seconds and
in 49 seconds at a time
I could suck in perpetuity you know like
at 49 seconds at a time
I could be all-time terrible especially
me that gets hot and competitive and
like you know like this is how I am when
the lights come on so I deal with the
negativity with empathy to the person
that's leaving the comment a for the
fact that I feel bad
because they're in a bad place that they
decided to put more heat into the system
and be like they shouldn't do seven
hours of research of my career or Who I
am as a human being I would be upset if
you thought I was a hmm because you've
had enough interactions at this point to
have a read rule number 49 have
self-awareness somebody asked me today
in an interview what do I do with my
downtime I told them that I start other
businesses it's all I know it's Who I am
it's the same way when I see a teacher
or an artist or anybody when I can see
through their soul that they were meant
to cook or paint or build or whatever it
may be I get such happiness it's the
same reason that people that I went to
school with who make fifty three
thousand dollars a year but I know
they're so happy because it's what they
want they want to be home at 5 p.m. they
want to be on multiple sports teams they
want every weekend off they don't want
the pressure the greatest thing about
being a CEO founder entrepreneur is that
when there is success you get a
disproportionate amount of the credit
the problem with entrepreneurship is
when it fails you have nobody to blame
one of the things that I'm most worried
about is when you are a pure-bred
entrepreneur you don't care about losing
the process is your religion running the
company is your oxygen when you are not
and you're doing it for everybody else
or because it's cool when you fail you
will have no place to hide and your loss
will be very public and unavoidable the
reason I put so much pressure on people
being self-aware
is if you're a natural number 2 6 13 or
27 the negatives of being a number one
are overwhelming and very difficult to
quantify you have to ask yourself today
that when
our business fails are you okay with the
judgment of your family friends your
social media followers and the entire
world and if you are then you can move
on your merry way
but if you are not one of the great
ramifications of this golden era of
entrepreneurship is going to be the
enormous amount of depression and mental
illness when 99 percent of the
businesses fail and remember 50 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
don't let people put you in a box
everything like like be the greatest
actor actress singer be an accountant be
everything you can be like it you got
one life don't box everybody's trying to
put people box if you're talented enough
do everything if you're bo Jackson and
Deion Sanders play both personality so I
do both
some people are hip personalities but
can't run a business some can run a
business a kid some people can cook and
sing some people can't they do you like
if you can do comedy and music they know
if you're good enough you always get it
the rock was now he's a baller
businessman if you're good enough
nobody's gonna stop you I've got a
special bonus clip from Gary on how to
have a strong why that I really think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching and other videos are taking
action in your life for business and if
you're feeling bold leave your answers
in the comments below here we go
watch number one what box have people
put you in that you need to get out of
number two what do you need to better
prioritize in your life and number three
what's the impact that you want to make
I feel such a level of guilt and
gratitude a mix of the two of how I had
it that all I'm trying to do with my
popularity or my attention
is create the shield for you to point to
do you know how happy it makes me how
many people use my content to show to
the person they're fighting with
internally or subconsciously
to give them the air cover to do the
thing they want to do that makes me feel
incredible it's the great gift of my
life that a lot of people use my content
to give them permission to do the thing
that they want to do and that is what
drives me to fly across the whole world
and keep doing it that is unbelievably
fulfilling I'm gonna get mine I've news
for everybody I got mine long before I
got on stage and started doing stuff I
don't need to monetize my audience if
you want more garyvee check out the
other top fifty rules video made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
cuz they're on the phone anymore and you
could talk about a day and age when it
was simpler and nicer and all this
nobody gives up